I trade for just 60 to 90 minutes a day
and I'm consistently growing a small new
trading account in this video I'm going
to break down to you my simple one
minute scalping strategy that you can
use to start and grow a trading account
yourself you'll see exactly how I found
entered and managed each trade for a
profit step by step my strategy is all
about trading reversals I identify key
levels on a 15minute time frame and then
I zoom into a 1 minute time frame and
use my multi step entry checklist to
enter into trades that I'm going to walk
you through now there's five key
Concepts to drawing these support and
resistance levels and I've actually
created a free pdf that you can download
in the description of this video that
will drastically improve your chances of
drawing correct levels that will also
increase your chances of having this
strategy be profitable for you as well
now the biggest key to looking for these
reversals is always approaching it as
what is the market telling me in terms
of it reversing now this is a good
example of a trade on a small account
I'm kind of doing a small account
challenge right now and this is on a
small account and so I am risking $100
here betting that the market is going to
reverse off of this resistance level
that I've drawn and then you know
betting it to go probably kind of down
here and we'll talk about targets and
why that's a good Target later but if it
gets down there that's a good two three
times my risk and on a small account RIS
ring $100 that is a nice profit and so
the first thing that I'm looking for
obviously is that it comes up to that
level first right that is the number one
key thing to make reversal trading work
is the patience to just wait for the
market to come to an extreme and key
level you can even see the market came
here and reversed off of this little
area right here you can say well you
know it bounced here it bounced here it
bounced here and so maybe it bounces
here maybe I should have got that you
know maybe you even look at hindsight
and say oh I'll try and get that next
time but those don't work very often and
they're more likely to cause you to lose
money in the long run it's better to
just sit out kill that noise and wait
for the market to come to these extremes
and then when it's oversold or
overbought in this case you can capture
on that strong reversal to the downside
and so the first key that I like to use
is after it's kind of hit that level
again you can see it's not quite in my
zone but again it's so close it's good
enough the first thing is making sure
that uptrend is broken because when
you're counter Trend trading you don't
want to go against a trend because you
know it might come up to a level here
but it's in an uptrend and it's just
going to keep going right we don't know
these these levels aren't going to hold
every time it's not just blindly sell or
buy at these levels and so that's kind
of why I have this uptrend here is you
can see that we had strong bullish
candlesticks here and then it it kind of
started to break is it had a dogee here
it had a bearish candle here and then it
made kind of another push higher and so
for me that's good enough to say hey
yeah this strong kind of micro Trend
right here is broken and you can see the
Market's kind of being quick with its
reversals and so I'm okay with thinking
that that's a a good enough Trend break
certain kind of Trends they'll need
something else but in this case for this
kind of very one directional unhealthy
Trend it's good in in terms of clearing
that kind of need for a reversal break
and so after that my next key that I
like to look for is kind of a reversal
pattern or reversal Candlestick pattern
and so in this case the market started
to show some weakness here with this
kind of dogee here and this kind of red
bar and it broke that uptrend and then
it made these two candlesticks here
these bullish candlesticks breaking this
previous high this high right here
became a new one and for me that said
okay it's still going higher but as soon
as this big bearish Candlestick form
right here this big red one that to me
is showing it almost made a a micro
failed breakout it made that kind of
trap where it attempted to make a new
high and it it did it made us a new high
but barely at all you know it didn't
make much before this big bearish
Candlestick came in and so if I kind of
Zoom back in the recording and kind of
show you that in real time right now to
speed this up a little once this
Candlestick finishes forming I think
that's a a good signal for me and I want
to get in right there at the low of that
candle so my thought is okay I want to
get in when it kind of breaks the low of
this candle because to me that's a
strong enough signal that it's likely
going to reverse there and so you can
see initially it kind of starts to go
against me and doesn't look great
initially but you know that's where when
things reverse sometimes they take a
little while the market won't always
just reverse on a dime A lot of times
it'll come up like it did kind of start
to settle down and slow and lose some of
that momentum and strength and then it
will give it back up and start going and
so that's what I'm kind of looking for
and so for once I entered in there I
moved my stop Above This High because
the whole idea is if it comes up here
and knocks me out you know I'm looking
for that kind of quick reversal to fail
and I think if it comes up here comes
back down and and keeps going higher I
think that's a stronger uptrend it's had
a healthy pullback if it does that and
then it keeps going higher and you know
I I want to get out the idea is with
trading is you take your stabs they
either work out really quickly and
really well right away or they just
don't work out and you move on if you're
trying to force a trade in conditions
where it's just not great and not
working out you're going to lose money
if you try and enter in the market over
and over and so once it kind of got
going in my favor here and again this is
on a small account I think I'm risking
it honestly might be like $80 or $90 not
even 100 but the idea is I moved my stop
loss here to break even because well if
you look at where we're at here we had a
news this was just a news announcement
I'm trading the NASDAQ futures here
again you can kind of trade this on
anything you want because you're just
reading the candlesticks but there was
kind of a news announcement that made a
big spike right here and then from there
we've been in kind of this choppy range
and so My worry is here is I do think we
can reverse off of here and push back
down and kind of push back to here we'll
talk about that in a second but I'm
looking for you know that to reverse
right I don't want to lose money if
instead the Market's just going to be in
this mode where it kind of just sits
here and goes in a sideways chop I am
looking for kind of a little bit larger
of a move where I you know risk a small
amount and make a large amount and so
when it kind of had this initial move
right here and it could have reversed
right here off that big green candle and
I would like to get out at break even at
that point and so you know once it kind
of did that I moved to break even and
instead it kind of just had a little
pullback which is good actually in terms
of the health of this move down and then
from there once it starts to kind of
make a new low I actually moved my stop
loss down here again to again capture
some of those profits because I'm
thinking that this Market is pretty
tight I think it's more likely that it
kind of whips back and forth and I'd
rather get out with a small decent size
little one times my risk maybe one and a
half times my risk win versus leaving it
here and you know hoping a home run
happens because those do happen and I
catch those but you have to pick your
spots right you don't always want to be
managing the same way with your trades
and so here you can see that I've
actually drawn a downtrend line here and
I think that's a really nice way to
manage T because it looks like it's
starting kind of to be in this little
downtrend and the second thing is to
this area now this isn't a major support
level it's not something I have on a
larger time frame that's why there's not
really a Zone drawing there this is
where you want to use as smaller targets
for your trades though because
especially in a market like this where I
don't think it's going to be a home run
I think it's more likely to bounce and
reverse off of a micro support
resistance level now I'm not necessarily
taking my bets and trades off of those
levels but in terms of if I think the
Market's going to be pretty tight today
and I want to just capture a nice little
swing like this and then get out at at a
nice profit I'm okay using that and a
lot of the times when the market has a
big move like this kind of like we were
talking about earlier that it's a big
area where the market velocity off that
area was really big it's more likely
that when the market comes back down
there it's going to find a bounce and
it's going to find some buyers and
support and this trade right here is
going to dry up and slow down and I want
to capture my profits here because I'm
getting you know about two two and a
half times my risk on this trade and
that is a great trade to just
consistently make money and grow your
Trading account and again that's what
you want to start out with you don't
want to be trying to get home runs make
a ton of money make your small account
grow over time and then this you can 10x
this size I have trades on my channel
where this trade would be $2,000 and
it's the exact same setup and so
actually at that point you can see I had
my stop loss down there because I was
managing it pretty tight because we got
down to this area and it closed out
there and it actually started to reverse
and you can see it started to reverse
off that level now don't forget about
that PDF of the five key Concepts in the
description of this video and so just
looking at right here pause the video
and kind of think about what patterns
you're seeing that we just went over
there's a couple here that you can see
so I'm just going to give a couple
seconds just pause it and just kind of
see if you can see what these patterns
are and then from there to kind of walk
you through what I'm seeing is you know
we kind of have a big support excuse me
resistance level here and the markets
come up and you know kind of just a
methodical uptrend right and then all of
a sudden we have a massive move up
causing in my mind a a big shift you
know this is out of nowhere the the
trend was clearly just kind of chugging
along to its thing and then boom it has
a big move and so for me that's a switch
in what's going on an overe exhaustion
usually and so from there it moves up
pulls back has one more attempt higher
here and then kind of to zoom in on this
area looking at these candles sticks as
well is there's a three line strike
pattern here it kind of shows up a
little funky but you know it's pretty
much just a couple of sideways candles
and then it slowly moves up and then
over this Candlestick here it moves up
and reverses and then the next candle it
just gives it back up and so for me I
you know waited to see a couple
candlesticks how it responded you know
that's kind of the intricacies of
getting in short and just playing these
strategies over time you'll kind of see
how you like to play in a couple spots
but then I entered in on a trade there
put my stop loss above here because my
thought is hey if it comes up here I
just want to get out you know this is
obviously a strong move if it's going to
keep going higher it's going to go
pretty quickly or if it if it reverses
and gives back this move up I like it's
going to happen quickly as well because
these moves they generally happen
quickly and so this is again on a small
account I'm risking about $100 here
maybe a little even under I don't quite
remember but the big thing I'm looking
for here is zooming it forwards a bit is
I went to break evening here once it
kind of gets moved in my favor and you
know you can see I drew this support box
because my thing is I'm thinking that
it's going to a lot of times like we
talked about earlier with these targets
or with these moves a good Target is it
gives back this kind of overextension or
OV exhaustive move that happens a lot of
the time and once it kind of gives back
there then it's kind of you know it's
back more in equilibrium and you know I
for me my Edge is gone on you know I I
have a good understanding of how these
move I don't have a good understanding
of how they move after but that's okay
right you only need one or two patterns
to be consistently profitable trading
and so this is my pattern right and so
for me I liked the idea of scaling out
of my trade this is a little more
advanced but I you know broke up my stop
losses of saying okay I want to get out
of you know three out of five of my
contracts right here if it decides to
snap back quickly and then I also want
to just kind of give this other one a
little more wiggle room if it's going to
bounce here and then keep going lower
you know this can be a big switch in the
overall trend and so I want to give it a
little room you know as you can see I
moved it down there I do kind of have a
kind of mental stop in my head now I
quickly moved it back but you can see
I'm kind of I'm trying to give it a
couple of candlesticks of a pullback
here and then most likely I'll move it
down once it kind of starts to reverse
or you know kind of gets to either 1X
risk you know the idea is I want to give
it some wiggle room but I don't want to
try and give it you know give this whole
swing back up and so kind of it starts
to reverse there and so I'm going to
move my stop down now because this is
kind of a a little micro top you know I
think if it's going to make this little
micro double top and keep going lower
that's a great spot for my stop because
if it breaks this you know I think it's
you know it's it's kind of not doing
what I'm looking for and that's how I
like to manage my trade is if it's doing
what I want and and so from there you
know it just kind of chopped around a
little bit and looks like it was
breaking lower here and so it starts to
break lower I moving my stop down and
again it's still kind of in this range
you can see here and this kind of looks
like a little bit of a little mini fail
breakout you could even say um and I
believe it it knocks me out here and so
that trade still closed up at you know I
think two two times my risk really good
profitable trade right there which is
you know a great growth on a small
account now again to remind you just
make sure to get that PDF in the link
below with all these it will be really
helpful for you to dive even more into
technical analysis and reading
candlesticks which is crucial for
trading this kind of style check out
this video right here I go even more in
depth onto the nuts and bolts of how
reading into the price movement of the
market and it will flush out these ideas
and patterns even more for you